news on this sex offender creep in new
york who sucker punched a man fracturing
his skull and nearly killing him he's
finally back behind bars where he
belongs the arrest happening only after
major public outcry over lacks bail laws
that let him roam around the big apple
today new york governor kathy hulkel
acting like it was her idea
never mind this new york post cover that
called her out
i took action in my own hands
i directed the department of corrections
and community supervision to immediately
examine whether or not this parole
violation occurred yes it did you could
tell it occurred this was a person on
lifetime parole
and as of
minutes ago that person is now in
custody that is at my direction the
people of new york need to know
that as their governor i'll stand up and
protect
but this was just one of the many crimes
that have happened under her watch video
obtained by the new york post shows
brazen thieves robbing a coffee shop and
customers at gunpoint right across from
the office of a top defund the police
politician and the democrat city carnage
doesn't end there it's complete anarchy
over in los angeles video showing a
flash mob ransacking a 7-eleven and
leaving the place in shambles all right
katie i'm going to start with you i i
can't get over the hutzpah this governor
yeah i directed the department of
corrections uh
it would certainly seem like a violation
governor with all due respect or
whatever respect you think you're
entitled to this was an attempted murder
the police made an arrest a progressive
d.a made a decision to lower that from
an attempted murder to a misdemeanor
assault three which is not a bail
eligible crime let's be clear just for
the viewers this man suffered a
fractured skull a broken cheekbone a
brain bleed he is in a coma this was
totally unprovoked the dirt bag who did
it right there on camera you could put
this in front of a jury and and tell
them to run the tape and then go to the
deliberation room and vote this dirt bag
is a sex offender level three level
three means he is the most dangerous he
is the most likely to reoffend and he is
endangered to the community he is not
only a sex offender he is an individual
who has been convicted of several felony
crimes now this obviously the reason she
wants to take credit is because she's
running for office does she deserve
credit
congratulations you put one guy back in
jail after he was let out and should
have never been let out given you saw
his mug shot many of them on the screen
he could have hurt someone else in the
time that he was out of jail and as you
said the charges are being
lowered which means that there's no
deterrence next time around for him or
for other criminals watching this who
are saying oh well if i do something
heinous like this i can just get off and
and
not be prosecuted by the system uh she
is running against lee zeldin who is a
republican running on a tough on crime
policy position that's why she's taking
this into her own hands um it's a good
thing this guy's back behind bars but
she could do bigger things like fire the
progressive d.a in new york city alvin
bragg and also generally speaking you
know the issue about the way that crime
has run so
rampant and out of control is it's going
the further along it gets
the further the solution is going to
need to be extreme so new york needs a
mayor not like eric adams who talks a
lot about fighting violent crime but
isn't doing much to solve the problem
they need something like rudy giuliani
no tolerance policies broken window
theory and really going hard after these
guys there's a deterrence and no
tolerance for criminal rights but rather
more
empowerment of victims and preventing
this from happening to other people you
know the the the point that katie makes
is a good one tyrus and that is that you
know we've got these liberal deas this
is uh i believe this is a a bronx case
and the bronx d.a is the one who made
the decision to reduce it to a
misdemeanor now what's crazy about this
tyrus is new york city cop said this is
attempted murder i'm telling you it's
attempted murder now
if they reduce it to a misdemeanor
there's going to be a public outcry
because it was they made it essentially
bail eligible now they say they're still
investigating if they're still
investigating it why did they reduce it
to a misdemeanor and let the guy out on
the street well we're still
investigating means like oh wow people
are really paying attention to this who
filmed it i think you need to look at
what the real issue is is intent
this dude this is not two guys who got
an argument and a fight broke out and
somebody got punched and got their job
broke this is a guy who saw his victim
put gloves on
measured him up and laid him out that's
intent that's straight up intent he
planned it and then here's the cold part
he didn't run away he wasn't in fear he
stood over him he admired his work and
he casually strolled off what we're
seeing is you can make arguments about
political people all you want to but the
embracement of the defund the police
movement
we're seeing premeditated brazen that
group that robbed the 7-11 that was
planned it was probably a facebook party
criminals are emboldened because there
is no fear it used to be when you see
someone get attacked they would do it
and they would run they'd go to escape
there's no reason for an escape even
though they re-arrested him they still
didn't say we're going to move this up
to attempted murder
the victim
has bleeding on his brain so he's never
going to quite be the same he's a broken
cheekbone he's a shark not to mention
he'll probably never sleep right again
for the rest of his life all of that if
that was if i did that to somebody it
would be attempted murder period
and we still don't know if this guy's
even going to make it through all this
there's complications he has
unbelievable amounts of surgery going
ahead but what it all comes down to is
you have emboldened the criminal element
and even with this arrest
it's still the same message they didn't
put any new charges they're
investigating what else do you need to
see well they didn't do any new charges
in fact what they did was she didn't say
we've arrested him joey and now you know
he's gonna he's gonna pay for what he
did she said well it's a violation of
parole well violation of parole is you
don't get in trouble you got in trouble
and you got arrested but let's talk
about the fact that that now what you've
got are these you know flash parties or
or facebook parties where they decide
they're going to all gang up and go into
a store and literally strip it of
everything on the shelves
where are we i mean i don't even know
the question to ask at this point nobody
even stops these kids and says you can't
com you can't you can't do this anymore
the question i ask is of new yorkers
which is how much does this matter to
you because they get to go vote here and
decide who they're going to have
representing them and what laws they
want to keep
i was made aware of a saying very
abruptly in eod school and military
school to be a bomb tech which is don't
apply a band-aid fix to a tourniquet
problem
and so without being too graphic you can
kind of understand what that means what
happens here is this guy isn't in jail
because of the nature of his crime he's
simply in jail because committing a
crime violated his parole from what i
understand and what really irks me the
most is we show this screenshot this
this screen full of
mug shots and say
with this history of violence he should
be behind bars with all due respect no
with this one incident he should be
behind bars it's common sense that if
someone goes out on the streets with the
intent to harm people they don't deserve
to be out on the street that is a very
simple thing and if new york laws are
stopping that from happening then new
yorkers need to fix this by getting new
people in office and it's not just new
york uh it jessica it's across the
country it is you know this cashless
bail the social justice progressive deas
worried more about criminals and victims
and and one situation where people are
having coffee uh and outside of a coffee
shop and a a bunch of guys come out with
guns with the extended magazines and
they hold them up for their watches and
their bracelets directly across the
street from new york city councilwoman
who who wants a deal and has defunded
police when are they going to understand
that they're not in this for us
it seems like election times are looking
like that and recall efforts are
happening all over the country and
they're being pushed forward by
democrats i was doing some research
about the recall of chesabuddin and it
was fueled in the beginning from
disillusioned asian-american democrats
who were like this is not okay anymore
and after the past few years of hate
crimes
against asian americans they said enough
is enough on this and to joey's point
about voting i went and voted this
morning i live in the new york ten
district our primary is on monday i did
early voting it's the district that's
was full bill de blasio was in it for
you know five seconds but dan goldman is
running in it who was the chief
prosecutor in the trump impeachment
donald trump did endorse him on true
social so now we've voted for the same
or endorsed the same candidate but which
is a little strange but what's really
interesting in
the debate between dan goldman and his
much more progressive counterparts who
are running as well is that the
progressives someone like mon marin who
was a legal aid lawyer
talks openly about how bad alvin bragg
is and goldman had endorsed alvin bragg
when he was running for for d.a so
you're seeing people who are more
traditionally progressive left of a
moderate democrat on every single issue
except for crime now
and saying that this has to be about
victims it can't be about protecting
criminals anymore and that is a trend
that you're going to see across the
entire country incarcerated person sorry
yeah that's right incarcerated the
problem is the problem with that is no
one's incarcerated yeah yeah that's good
there's a few people in there yeah yeah
and of course what tyrus is referencing
is that they change the law in new york
they're no longer inmates they're
incarcerated people sales salesperson
salesperson hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else